we have a voicemail number 219 to david
p the rare positive voicemail every once
in a while we do get one and you know
it's it's the new year and we want to at
least somewhat start off on a positive
note let's take a listen to this but
that man you keep rockin on but I'm a
supporter and i think that the American
people just need to know the truth and
more yes I mean what a wonderful earth
we live you rock on right you keep done
it all right but I a very positive very
very excited person yeah on the bonus
show today we will talk about routine
jobs disappearing it's not what you
might think of a restaurant in Montreal
is offering free food to those who can't
afford to pay and it's costing them
effectively nothing i'll explain why and
also yesterday i was able to get a tour
of the MBTA which is the Transit
Authority in Massachusetts of their
control center absolutely fascinating
and I want to talk about that on the
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership and remember we have normal
membership rates six bucks a month sixty
dollars a year I think it's a great
value there you get so much the bonus
show commercial free audio of the show
commercial free video of the show
etcetera if the prices are too high and
you want to become a member I still want
you to be able to so we have a coupon
code which is I voted 17 all one word
all lower case and that gives you a huge
discount off of membership I don't even
want to say how big it is because it's
huge uh and and uh it's something that a
lot of people have been taking advantage
of I want you involved at whatever level
is comfortable to you because if we get
buy-in from more people it doesn't
matter that it's at a discounted rate we
just want to continue growing the
coalition can get and growing the reach
and power of the program and that's only
going to happen if people continue to
sign up for membership last thing before
we go four thousand dollar matching
challenge grant the next four thousand
dollars that we raised there's about
twenty eight hundred dollars left to
raise of this four thousand dollar
challenge will be matched
dollar-for-dollar by an anonymous donor
you've gotta donate by midnight January
sixth david pakman.com slash donate get
those donations in